They're just like us.
Olivia Munn's cute.
She's pretty.
Don't you think she's pretty?
Yeah, she's cute.
Channing Tatum has
a new movie coming out.
He's so hot.
You think he's hot?
I wouldn't know. Seriously?
You think it makes you gay to
acknowledge that a guy's hot?
I-- I can't tell,
I like girls, all right?
Yeah, but come on,
you can just admit that.
Can we just drop it?
Fine.
But I mean, you see no
difference between, like,
Eugene Levy
and Channing Tatum?
Nope.
If they both needed
mouth-to-mouth, you don't think
it would be grosser
to give it to Levy?
It would be equally gross.
You're lying.
Okay, okay, you're asleep,
and you wake up to what
you think is me
going down on you
but then you look
next to you,
and I'm laying in the bed.
And then I say, "Eugene Levy is
on your penis right now."
but then you look down, and
it's actually Channing Tatum.
Wouldn't you be, like,
slightly relieved
and, like, finish?
No.
But you thought it was me
up until the very end.
Okay, stop making me think
about this, all right?
Oh, my God, you're so
homophobic.
Imagining a hot guy's mouth
around your junk
doesn't all of a sudden
make you not straight.
Okay.
You're in jail, okay?
And these guys have you
surrounded in the shower,
and there's no way out of it.
You've already just given over
to the fact that you are
definitely about to take it
right in the butthole.
All right?
Okay, can we please just
not talk about it.
No, no, no, no, no.
You're being silly about
something so meaningless.
Just listen,
you're in jail.
Okay, so you're
surrounded, okay?
But they give you a choice who
you're gonna get it from.
Four of the guys
are Eugene Levy,
and they haven't
showered in weeks.
But then there's Channing.
Beautiful, perfectly chiseled,
great at dancing, Channing.
He's fresh out of the shower,
and his hair looks
professionally done,
but you know it just
fell like that.
What?
Just tell me you know what
a handsome man looks like
and I will leave you alone.
Okay, I can see how
Channing Tatum might be
a little bit
good-looking.
Are you happy?
Jesus!
Get it.
(sighs)
Hey, sorry to interrupt,
but I can't find my cat.
Have you seen it?
Oh.
Hey.
Wow.
Oh.
I'm John.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'll find your cat.
What's his name?
I'll figure it out.
Take my pants off.
Yeah, okay.
Get in there.